[Música]
qué tal si el futuro de la moda fuera
digital una fusión entre el mundo físico
y el digital las medidas de
distanciamiento físico significan que no
veremos desfiles de moda con un tiempo
en su lugar estos están siendo
reemplazados por cortometrajes pensados
para ser repetidos una y otra vez en las
redes sociales a veces son una simple
sucesión de productos como en este
comercial del hongo grabado en el
palacio ideal del carteros oral pero
cada vez más a menudo son historias en
las que compiten la estética y el
activismo hagamos un recorrido por lo
mejor y lo peor de lo que este tipo de
comunicación en el mundo de la moda nos
ofrece en las redes sociales empecemos
con louis vuitton y un diseño gráfico
alucinante que nos hace pensar en los
vídeos de hip hop de la costa oeste de
eeuu de los años 2000 bird y la blog
encargado de las colecciones masculinas
de la marca nos lleva a un país de las
maravillas donde extrañas criaturas
sobrevuelan parís
aquí las prendas juegan un papel
secundario en la historia y en la
atmósfera del universo artístico de la
marca
para la colección en sí y bill hablo es
activista no está presentando un corto
sino y cito un proceso transformador de
repensar y abolir las expectativas
heredadas y a menudo subconscientes
vinculadas a las identidades negras con
el fin de construir una conciencia negra
positiva para las generaciones actuales
y futuras
water el dúo caribeño neerlandés libre a
la misma batalla un semi bote es negro
viene de curazao y siguen en broad es
blanca viene de dominica
diseñaron su colección durante el
confinamiento usando el stock que tenían
en su estudio su vídeo lucha contra el
racismo en el aparecen entre otros y en
qué ahmet allí el estilista de beyoncé
naomi campbell y kim kardashian en
cuanto a sus prendas
el dúo ofrece una divertida experiencia
en 3d donde uno puede vestir a su propio
avatar negro
nuestro siguiente manifiesto viene de
gran bretaña
no estamos frente a la obra punk de una
marca ultra moderna sino frente a una
declaratoria de amor hacia la comunidad
lg vete tú más de la icónica marca del
estampado a cuadros burberry con música
de finales de los 90 interpretada por la
cantante estadounidense ultra nate este
corto de celebración fue grabado en casa
durante el confinamiento un periodo que
cambió la forma en que muchos de
nosotros nos vestíamos hasta el punto de
que algunas veces ya no nos reconocíamos
issey miyake título su obra me dió
newsouth conoce a tu nuevo yo la casa
japonesa estrella de los años 90 sugiere
que reflexionemos sobre la siguiente
pregunta existencial luego de pasar por
una crisis seguimos siendo los mismos
[Música]
la moda a menudo puede parecer
superficial pero también aborda grandes
preguntas filosóficas quién soy qué
estoy haciendo hacia dónde voy muy cerca
de su estudio en el distrito 20 de parís
el colectivo parisino es u2 realizó un
largo plano secuencia de chicos que se
cruzan sin hablarse ni tocarse es miedo
alcohol o es una prueba de la falta de
comunicación entre las personas
muy bien y él por su parte decidió
darles a los espectadores un vistazo
detrás de las escenas de su arte
vemos una serie de suntuosos trajes
expuestos en un estudio la escena rezuma
glamour y generosidad
pero hay una duda por debajo de todo
esto
[Música]
es decir si esto favorecerá las ventas
no creo que esto favorezca nuestras
ventas de alta postura pero sé que esto
atrae a la gente especialmente a los
jóvenes y eso ya es genial porque nadie
entiende realmente no es de saba así que
si esto le ayuda a las generaciones
jóvenes a entender lo que la excelencias
realmente significan nuestro mundo bueno
eso es genial ya es algo serradilla
mientras tanto en bruselas en el parque
del cincuentenario
el diseñador belga edouard vermaelen
dirige una sesión de fotos que también
se transformará en un corto refinado
elegante y con pocos modelos
edición de provisionamiento estábamos
haciendo productos de hecho estábamos
sacando más porque teníamos no tener
suficiente para nuestros clientes o más
bien para nuestra distribución y por
supuesto siempre podemos hacer un mejor
trabajo y es mejor estudiar 20 modelos
cuidadosamente que 40 porque
lastimosamente no tienes tiempo para
realmente estudiarlos con precisión es
extremadamente importante para mí hacer
las cosas bien y en eso estamos
trabajando
[Música]
este corto vídeo es de la joven
diseñadora este el curio le fascinan los
tesoros escondidos que se encuentran en
las tiendas en segunda mano es una
defensora del reciclaje y odia el
desperdicio la mayoría de las prendas
que selecciona provienen de grandes
marcas compradas por entre 3 y 5 euros
en tiendas vintage en el extremo opuesto
de esta moda simple estaba alma para
celebrar el aniversario número 75 de la
marca olivia gusta exhibe al amor de su
vida en el sena parís la colección rinde
homenaje a los estilos de sus
predecesores desde eric mortensen a
óscar de la renta
el evento fue transmitido en vivo no en
youtube sino en la aplicación china tick
tock
y por ultimo alejémonos de parís vayamos
al parque nacional del bec sa a una hora
de la capital
es aquí donde saqué mi realizó amor o
amor su desfile de 2021 más tarde
utilizado para este cortometraje 55
trajes 110 invitados y un vasto campo de
trigo confabularon para crear una
maravilla digital porque cuando una
colección es realmente buena aunque en
el corto no pase nada realmente nos da
esa extraña sensación de sentir la
prenda sobre nuestra piel